19 children were shot dead at school in
ivalde texas yesterday
they were all under the age of 12
slaughtered in their classroom by an 18
year old maniac who just bought the guns
he used for his 18th birthday present
these children's parents took them to
school yesterday morning their young
hearts joyful with excitement for
another day of education and fun with
their friends
but they never went home when they're
never going home
and those parents will never recover now
from the loss of their children the
shooter salvador ramos legally spent
five thousand dollars buying two ar-15
semi-automatic rifles and
375 rounds of ammunition just a few days
after his 18th birthday
and yet he couldn't have legally bought
a beer in texas for another three years
nor could he have bought a kinder
surprise chocolate egg anywhere in
america because they're banned over the
choking thread of the toys inside
you don't have to be pro or anti-gun
control to realize this is bafflingly
inconsistent
just as it seems absurd that there's no
law in forcing universal background
checks on all gun sales when 91 of
americans in the polls want them to
happen
and those background checks must include
all potentially relevant information
ramos was known to police after violent
arguments with his drug abusing mother
and firing bb guns and we now know he
posted his plan to attack a school on
facebook before carrying it out
the supermarket shooter in buffalo new
york peyton gendron was also 18 when he
murdered 10 black people in a white
supremacist rampage just 10 days ago
he bought his guns legally too and was
also known to police after threatening
to shoot up a school the sandy hook
shoot at adamanza was 20.
and banning people from being able to
buy guns until they're 21
won't stop all young men like this
getting their hands on guns but
shouldn't we at least make it more
difficult for them it takes a mentally
ill monster to gun down innocent
children
it's also monstrous to what should
happen time and again and do nothing
isn't it scarlett lewis's son jesse was
just six years old when he was killed
along with 19 other students and six
adults i can't believe that i'm
standing here talking to you ten years
after the murder of my own son jesse at
sandy hook alongside 19 of his first
grade classmates and six educators and
now here we have another one after
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
school shootings later and of course
columbine 20 years before and we are
still hearing the same tired narrative
it is so frustrating i want to take you
back to what happened to your boy he was
six years old and he was an absolute
little hero because he was in the
classroom when the
the shooter adam lanza came in and his
gun jammed and your little lad jesse
shouted at his friends to get out of the
classroom which a large number of them
did i think eight or nine of the kids
got out and then he was shot dead uh a
absolute hero was that in keeping with
his character
absolutely that was jesse uh and i i if
he wasn't coming back as we waited for
those hours i knew that he would have
done something brave and when the the
shooter had shot his way through the
glass doors of sandy hook elementary
school he made a left
down the first grade hallway of course
he knew where that was because he had
attended that school
the principal and guidance counselor
were meeting with a parent they were
startled they opened the door to see
what
what the the the noise was all about
they were gunned down and then the
shooter turned into jesse's first grade
classroom everyone was scattered his gun
actually ran out of bullets at that time
and during the short delay that it took
him to change his clip
jesse called for his classmates to run
and he is credited with saving nine of
his classmates lives before losing his
own when you were in a dinghy yourself
risking your life for freedom escaping
the hell of the war in syria
put me into that dinghy for a moment
what was it like to be in one of those
dinghies knowing you might actually die
well it's horrible because you feel like
your cargo you feel like you are you
don't feel human anymore and you're
treated as a number um and did i expect
ever in my life when i grew up in
damascus that this will ever happen to
me no because i lived a comfortable life
i lived an incredible life but you hit
rock bottom within a second you know
we've we
it just happens in a blink of an eye and
then when through the lottery of the
world you are born with a passport that
you can't get visas anywhere you can't
get on a plane and go to britain or to
america or anywhere in europe then you
are forced to travel on that boat it is
dehumanizing it is painful and it's it's
quite sad and then imagine having
traveled for thousands of miles risked
your life crossed on a boat and then
came to britain expected that you will
be
dealt with with respect with dignity
with humanity and then the government
here decides you to put decides to put
you on a plane and send you to arawanda
to rwanda to a country that you have no
connections with no no community no
friends
thank you so much man
i've never been on the street before
i've been on the streets before i stayed
at the shelter yeah and also it wasn't
scarborough homeless this is for you
what is it it's for helping me
what is it
check what's inside
[Music]
500.
yes sir thank you bro
love you bro
i started making the videos about a year
ago now
it all really stemmed from when i was
depressed and borderline suicidal in
medical school i was studying medicine
at the university of sydney
and it was almost a cry for help at the
time i made a video about depression and
what i was going through um and then it
just took a life of its own over the
last 10 months this video right here
where i'm blindfolded hugging a stranger
is i'm blindfolded because
i
didn't know how to connect with my
family and friends back home when i was
depressed and suicidal and i found it
much easier to connect the stranger i
hug people because i haven't hugged
someone in two years and i tell
strangers every time i meet them that i
love them because no one told me they
loved me in two years
so a lot of what i do in terms of giving
back or connecting with individuals on
the streets is just rooted in my lowest
times
i would
say that this battle is definitely
the most
important of
our lives
of the ukrainians there's so many
children that been suffering
killed or injured up to
1 000 children we can't really
give exact numbers because the numbers
are still going on and counting this
genocide of the ukrainian population
must be stopped and this is not the word
that the world
should be scared of even think about it
or pronounce it it is
happening
in ukraine
and i want to use just one one moment of
of
of this monologue
and say thank you to great britain
boris johnson that has stepped in he was
trying a lot from the early beginning
to find
the way how he can talk
to putin
how he can prevent the first steps that
unfortunately were made and the lines
were crossed
and all the support and supply that
we were receiving from the
beginning and this is so great
to have allies and partners of
our nation
right now there's this grizzly trial
going on about probably one of the worst
toxic marriages i think i've ever
witnessed between johnny depp and amber
herb we've had two trials now in the
middle of the second one
does this kind of thing actually is it
damaging to the calls that you're trying
to advance and promote
i mean this is such like as a very
sensitive topic for me because it's so
personal
but um
to me this trial is is so this case is
so not entertainment for me
and what i what i worry about is it's
gonna damage you know future men or
women coming forward and making their
own claims or the justice system having
doubt or not believing because at the
end of the day you know we can't get
away from the fact that two women get
killed every week in this country by
their former partner or their current
partner as opposed to 12 men a year so i
have to kind of remind myself that i'm
glad that people are aware of the
situation which is an epidemic of
domestic violence and coercive control
and any form of abuse but i also think
that to look at this case as
entertainment is damaging and that's why
i have not even look to it at all it
really
made me have like a lump in my throat to
think that this is televised because i
know when i went through all my stuff in
the us
i i actually had to like file court
papers to be to have a closed um
courtroom because otherwise tmz we're
going to be allowed in and all these
different outlets and
cameras and filming and all that stuff
and luckily the judge granted me for it
to be a closed call if you could look
back over your entire life and career
if i had the power to let you relive
one moment again what would you choose
i wish
that i could have
known my father better
right yeah it's taken a moment uh to
to know him but he was
scottish and um
he was 56 when he died and he was pretty
burned out anyway but
um
i i'm sorry about that i would like to
have known him better it was an
interesting time in your life because i
think you were 15 weren't you when he
died and he
he never really supported you in your
dream of becoming an entertainer
well i knew he was going to die i kept
telling everybody in the family i said
i think he's going to die and
my grandmother said what are you talking
about i said i can see it
they couldn't see it
and he did he right in front of me
it happened
i have this ability sometimes to
know what is going to happen before it
does
when you got fired
you get turfed out by the cancel culture
mob twitter is a blaze
they're joyful they're gleeful they've
got rid of you they've they've got you
out of that job they've had you fired
for having an opinion what was going
through your mind when when the first
few days after that it was um listen i
don't scare easily you know that
but
some of the
comments that were coming through on my
social media were so horrific about
cutting my throat my husband even the
dogs they wanted to kill my dogs and
then they started on aussie on his site
and then my kids what i'm also
interested in is what happened to you
later because
your life i mean it didn't completely
fall apart because you had your family
but it was incredibly tough for you
it was tough for me and it did affect me
um mentally i i it honestly did because
after
everything that i'd felt all my dreams i
had achieved everything that i'd wanted
to do i had achieved and did i want my
legacy for my family to be oh well your
nana was on television but everybody
said she was racist so she never went on
television again and that kind of
act me on what did that do to you it
kept me up i couldn't i must have cried
for three months
never stop crying and my friend
um
sarah gilbert who used to you know
right she she was the one that came up
with the idea for the show and was on it
and she said you need help um you've got
to go somewhere and she recommended
somewhere and then i was doing therapy
and ketamine treatment did you get
suicidal at any stage
not suicidal because i didn't want to
give
cbs the satisfaction rita let me ask you
it's also very courageous for both of
you to be speaking out to the world's
media in the way that you are right now
are you not concerned or fearful of what
the taliban may do if you do interviews
like this we have affair that when the
taliban just
watching this interview they will be
uh uh take some actions like now
uh while the our male colleagues wearing
masks they have some issues like they
and the social media they posted that
while uh male colleagues wearing masks
they should be wearing shawl or they
should be wearing work as well that they
showed their solidarity with their
female goats
so we have a concern not just about the
our security job like we will be lost
our job we have other
other security fairs and maybe they
target us or maybe they target other
family members uh we are concerned about
all these things let the women get back
to their life let them enjoy their
freedom that the god has given them the
islam has given them let the girls come
back to schools millions of years of
waiting just for us a decree asking them
to return to this school there are
millions of people it's not only
millions of people there are millions of
hopes millions of
of lives you know
uh
yeah these are what we want from them
and i hope they consider we are
supportive but we are from the same
nation we are the same people
if you don't join hands together i don't
think that
we will survive or they will survive
you